today I'll stick to football we are
gonna update you on all things to ins
hung a viola talked about maybe the end
of Philip Rivers at least with the Los
Angeles chargers and we're gonna fix the
Chicago Bears and give you a little bit
of a stock watch Connor Rodgers want me
to show buddy yeah dude it's uh it's
it's good to be back on the midweek show
we got a little rest a little energy now
but not for long because the tailgate
tour rolls on this weekend we will be at
Stanford for Stanford Cal this Saturday
I believe kick-off local time is 1:00
p.m. but you know how stick the football
does it we will be getting there at what
do you think Matt 8:00 a.m.
usually usually how we do it and Matt
once you give the people a little bit of
the details on where our tailgate tent
is gonna be this weekend yeah we've been
tweeting out links photos of where will
be the the tailgate guys are who we're
partnering with we love this crew and
right off of El Camino rial there's
masters Grove so if you're a Stanford
person you know this a lot better than I
do
we're right there so we're very close to
this the football stadium look for tent
number five it's these big white tents
tailgate guys signage very easy to find
we're tent number five it's an enormous
tent we're gonna have TVs couches food
all kinds of beverages water soda beer
maybe cocktails so come by it's all free
look you don't have to take it to the
tailgate you don't have to have a ticket
to the game we will have TVs on so if
you don't want to miss the morning games
we'll have game day on in the morning
we'll be showing the 11 a.m. games on
eleven eight in central games everything
right up until kickoff when we go into
the game so it's give me a great time
come find us again whether you're a
Khalfan stanford fan it doesn't matter
to us just look for tent number five
right off of El Camino Real
yeah we're not done there because the
tailgate tour had ever mentioned tacked
on it's like the 17 game proposal from
the NFL that happened at the tailgate
tour only we're definitely saying yes
every time we're going to be at the SEC
Championship by partnering with
Johnsonville right outside mercedes-benz
stadium that's on December 7th they're
gonna have a cookout Sean Alexander is
gonna be joining stick to football it's
gonna be all kinds of fun so if you're
anywhere in the Atlanta area that
weekend you know where you want to be
come hang out with Styx football in
Johnsonville but let's get into the
actual football news and let's kick
things off with what we saw on Monday
night in Mexico
Philip Rivers Matt baby not good the it
just is very reminiscent of Peyton
Manning's arm at the end of his career
where there's just not much juice left
in the tank and I hate to see it I love
rivers I love the energy even the drive
to get them down the field what catch by
Mike Williams who I think is actually a
little bit underrated right now even if
you might have been over drafted he's
been very impressive
but Matt we got to talk about is this
the end of the Philip Rivers era you
know I think it's interesting for a lot
of reasons because number one he's a
free agent after this year and I mean
I've said it for a couple weeks now
talking to a lot of people the
expectation was always that he would
resign on a one or two year deal give
them time to kind of find a bridge
quarterback a quarterback in the future
but I think his play and their play as a
team this year is a little bit i opening
to where it is a little reminiscent of
Peyton Manning of Eli Manning of guys
once they hit upper 30s the arm strength
just falls off and with rivers who's
always had such a funky throwing motion
I think we're seeing more of that now
like more sidearm passes more
knuckleball type throws to where he's
not as fluid you see the arm tightening
up and I think that it's affecting
accuracy it's it's starting to affect
his decision-making is maybe he doesn't
want to make some of the more
challenging throws and actually I'm
mellow and I watched the game last night
I told him I haven't seen rivers like
this chirpy in a long time and he's
always like a [ __ ] talker but he just
seems upset and you have to wonder if
he's you know kind of at the end of his
road with this team and if it will be a
vice-versa situation Tom telesco and
Anthony Lin have completely avoided
drafting a quarterback of the future I
know they took Easton stick very late
but that's not an investment in a real
you know replacement at the quarterback
position this is something they have to
start thinking about and this ties in
with everything else that's going on in
the world of football right now where
they are selected to pick they are not
getting Joe burrow
they're not getting Justin Herbert
they're maybe in Mike Jeff Monday we
gave them two at Unga by law right now
they would pick at 11 overall and to us
a pretty massive risk I think everyone
can understand that because we just
don't know anything right now so if
you're the Chargers you're really stuck
in a bad situation here with rivers
being
short-term option at best and may be
gone this year in free agency well
here's my question for you Matt if
that's the case is there a tease under
contract for one more year after this
season is there any way that Tyrod
Taylor gets a shot again oh man ain't
maybe but you know the NFL is changing
to where what tie rod was great at
before might work a little bit better if
Anthony Lin wants to go all-in on that
like yeah maybe that maybe that could
work but I just I think we've seen what
tie rod is and like you know even back
in Buffalo and he was playing really
well for some spurts it just it wasn't
good enough so he's also getting a
little bit older I don't know if that
would be the the case if if somehow you
know Rivers leaves and and I've said
before I've heard he wants to get back
to closer to where he's from and
northern Alabama the Titans are gonna
have a need at quarterback maybe he gets
back there tie rods gonna be 31 next
year and next year is his last year as a
charger as well so yeah I mean I think
he is worth the shot right if you can't
get one of the high level quarterbacks
in this year strap maybe you say we'll
roll a Tyrod Taylor will draft a Jalen
Hertz and try to develop him at the
quarterback position and all right
look we're gonna commit to this like the
Cardinals like the Ravens we're gonna
commit to a type of offense and I think
you could even say this about the Chiefs
they committed to a type of offense
that's different than what Andy Reid
traditionally does so I think it would
be fun and I think teams are gonna have
to be creative and think outside the box
because the Joe burrows the Justin
Herbert's they're gonna come off the
board incredibly early so like Baltimore
when they took Lamar Jackson yeah okay
well we like this guy we think he can do
this we're just going to have to adapt
our system to fit him and I think if
you're the Chargers you might want to
start having those conversations of we
can't get a you know not a drop back
pasture because those are kind of dying
but a guy who's more of a pocket player
like burrow or like Herbert so maybe we
just shake things up and go with a Jalen
hurts who has struggled recently as a
pastor a little bit but also you know
still looks impressive at times yeah I
think it's interesting because Anthony
Lynn was there in Buffalo all those
great Tyrod years he gets a head
coaching job and he brings tie rod to
the Chargers he had a phenomenal start
to his
coaching career with the Chargers and I
think I know it's Tyrod Taylor it's not
some stud or anything like that but I
think he's a guy that can hold the fort
if they want to take the risk on our
Jordan love a Jacob Eason yeah one of
those guys as you said Matt that hey you
did it in mocked ref Monday this is a
team that can wait onto a tongue of
Eylau ax that's what's so fascinating to
me here and actually think that's a good
landing spot for two if they can you
know add some more pieces to this
offensive line in the draft and for
agency as well there are a lot of
different options that they can go and
attack at the quarterback position but
they're not gonna be the only team you
know we're gonna talk about the Chicago
Bears and a couple segments another team
that they're gonna have be creative
filling their quarterback need because
they don't have a first-round pick and
they don't have a lot of cap space
speaking of - uh had surgery Monday
there's a video of him playing the
ukulele it's amazing the man can
actually sing it it's pretty good I
would buy the mixtape whenever - uh puts
it out but we do have a little bit of a
timeline again
Alabama's doctor surgeon is saying they
expect a full recovery in three months
time - will be cleared for athletic
activities and they expect he'll be
throwing by the spring what this tells
me though Conor and we expected this he
will not be ready for the NFL Scouting
Combine and anything that he can do pre
draft is gonna be pretty limited now the
good news if there can be good news is
when this injury happens in mid-november
there is enough time five months before
the NFL Draft in five months time the
hope is that you would have a pretty
good picture of what the hip looks like
but as you and I were talking about
before the show today this is a small
player who is not a big guy this is a
small player who's had three surgeries
in two years - on the ankle one on the
hip lower body injuries terrify me on
small players we talked about this with
Marquis Brown last year like a foot
injury any a knee injury on a small
player that's always gonna be a red flag
for me so John Ross
John Ross there's a lot of conversation
about what should - ado is it it's just
speculation and opinion at this point
but should he declare for the 2020 draft
there is enough time that he will be
about two months into his rehab when the
draft actually takes place yeah it's
really interesting I mean
you look at it it's kind of good news in
a sense where I think the time line is
not the worst case scenario and that he
will at least be able to attend things
like the combine maybe we'll see him
throw at some point if you can get in
front of teams even if it has to be past
the combine which is gonna be
interesting that because we know how
it's usually end of February first
weekend of March maybe this is one of
those things that goes down to the wire
where and you know the NFL and the draft
love drama I mean what if two hasn't
worked out the week of the draft and
teams end up scrambling he could I mean
he can absolutely do that when you look
at the timeline right right it makes
sense and we've seen exceptions for guys
with injury before where if he's
throwing in three months I mean that's
two months to prepare for some type of
limited pro day you know I I have so
many questions and because this is
medical related because of HIPAA laws
and privacy laws there gonna be a lot of
questions that we have that just don't
get answered like I know what are the
chances of arthritis what are the
chances what is the percentage of future
injury how's his ankle by the way you
know that was the problem before this so
they're there a lot of questions
surrounded to up but I will say I know
all of us here like wishing this dude
the best because before he got hurt he
was I think he was you don't want to
call anyone a lock in November he looked
like a lock to be a top five pick as
long as he took care of business the
rest the way so you hate to see it I
mean at worst it's gonna cost a millions
of dollars or at best it's gonna cost
him play dollars at worst you might
never play again so I know we're all
wishing him the best and hopefully the
rehab goes well take a break we come
back we were gonna look at stock watch
like we do every Wednesday morning it is
stock watch time on stick to football we
got a couple guys going up a couple guys
going down and I'm gonna start on the
downside we've talked a little bit about
this in previous weeks but grades out
but from LSU and I was looking at my big
board this morning adding in notes on
players and one thing that stood out to
me was I still have Grant Delpit ranked
relatively high I think right now he's
sitting at number 13 overall yeah that's
actually pretty good
here's what I'll say about this year's
draft class I wish I could put like a
brick wall between player 10 and 11
because it's actually like it should be
like 10 to 20 like there should be no
one ranked 11 to 19 there's just such a
big gap so that this is one of those
years where I'm like 13 is actually kind
of high but the difference between 13
and 10 are actually gonna be pretty
significant on my board but as far as
great Delpit goes connor we've talked
about this a lot you loved the
leadership you loved the character he's
a big guy 6 foot 3 or a tall guy 6 foot
3 but I have not loved the play he has
not had an impact game yet this year
he's been missing a ton of tackles we
haven't seen him really executing is
showing any ball skills that you can
even look at the Alabama game LSU won
that game grant Delpit was not a factor
on defense it was kay LaVon chase on it
was Patrick Queen it was a Vincent the
other safety I don't know where
Delbert's been all year I've said before
it reminds me of Derwin James last year
at Florida State but Darwin was coming
off injury so you could at least excuse
maybe he's trying to shake off some rust
with Delpit it just seems like a guy who
maybe got blew up a little bit by the
draft process if this is a top-10 pick a
great safety but he's no longer playing
like what made him that prospect yeah
I'm with you all the way I mean this is
why he fell all the way to Dallas in our
mock draft Monday which is quite the
fall for Delpit that was kind of a
top-10 lock for a while on mock draft
Mondays I think would Delpit you nail it
Matt where he's not wrapping up he's
missing a lot of tackles specifically
against a very good team like Alabama
where Nagi Harris made him look foolish
a couple of times at the second level of
the football field and I think Delpit
was on such a special trajectory as yeah
he was a really good freshman really
good sophomore he could do a lot in
coverage he could do even more at the
line of scrimmage and this you're just
not seeing the big plays to do that and
I think you know what's kind of crazy is
and I'm guilty of this when there's a
really great player at a position for a
school and then you see one behind him
that looks like he can be just as good
you fall into a hype trap and with LSU
it was Jamal Adams was one of the best
safeties we've seen in college football
in a very long time and then Delpit
comes in you go well that got wait till
that guy behind him wait till that guy
behind him and though it's a good player
but he's not Jamal Adams and it's it's a
shame we all fall into the hype trap and
I think that's what's happened with him
a little
but one guy stuck up this week and it
did not look pretty in the box score was
Jake from and I'll tell you why Jake
from understands the tempo of a game
when to take shots in a game I thought
that first quarter deep shot was a
beautiful throw one of his best I've
seen of his career and I think for from
we've said this before but with two
estat Asst up in the air a lot of
quarterbacks looking very very raw I'm
not ready to sit here and say Jake from
gets the first round great from me I'm
not saying that but what I am saying is
he might have a little more incentive to
declare this year because so many teams
need a quarterback and I think in the
right system with the right coach Jake
Fromm does the little things right where
he can win you football games and you
saw that against a very very good Auburn
defense this weekend I just really like
what I see from from I wouldn't bet my
franchise on him if I was a GM but if he
falls to the top of the second round
he's the kind of guy you take a swing at
all right that's what I think we get
asked a lot why don't you guys like Jake
from I know Melo who not with us on the
Wednesday show who loves Jake from I
like Jake from I know you do as well
it's just like we said before he's he's
not gonna impress you with his physical
tools he's gonna press you with his mind
with his game I mean I loved teddy
bridgewater coming out of Louisville
because same reason like you know it
doesn't have the biggest arm he's not
the biggest guy he's just so smart he's
accurate and I maybe I've been burned a
little bit by that type of player
because we're seeing trait guys who are
also good producers in college takeover
the NFL so Jake Fromm is it's still a
tough evaluation speaking of trait guys
who produce in college stock up for
Justin Herbert we have been I think
collectively pretty tough on Justin
Herbert at times and there are still
moments when I'm watching him play that
I want to see more but I think it would
be irresponsible to sit here and not say
that he's been impressive and I know the
doubters can say well it's just the
pac-12 and yes it was just Arizona that
they beat up on Saturday night
but some of the throws that he made in
that game were really really special
just showing touch an ability to attack
downfield I think there were times last
year and even early this year where we
didn't see Herbert play as aggressively
as his traits would suggest that he
could but now he is I don't know if
head coach Mario Cristobal took the the
chains off a little bit and is letting
him attack down feel more or this is
just a mentality from Herbert but he is
being much more aggressive and that's
making me like him more where I don't
just see a guy standing back in the
shotgun checking down I like that he's
taking some chances down the field
yeah I agree I'm not the biggest Herbert
guy but this was a weekend where if you
want to look for the tape if you're in
that war room and say hey we're taking
this guy with our first-round pick this
is the tape that you fire up for him all
right man the draft is a flat circle
here Matt but Travis etn stock of it has
been like this for him last year I loved
him when he wasn't eligible slow start
this year kind of wake me up when
September ends for ETN I don't know what
it was he starts out the season with
over 200 yards in an August game then
you look at his September games all four
of them he didn't have more than 76
rushing yards in any of them since then
he's gone over a hundred every single
time he's gone over 200 before he's come
close to 200 another time he's on fire
right now etn and remember how you said
on the Monday show people aren't paying
attention to how good clemson has picked
it up the last couple weeks
Trevor Lawrence the receivers they're
riding etn again well yeah when that's
clicking it helps everyone else and when
you look at Eaton I mean just the last
three games 7.6 yards of carry eight
yards of carry
twenty three point six yards per carry
etn is absolutely on fire I don't think
he's the best running back in this class
I still think that's the Andre Swift but
it would be a big surprise if he's not
top three for me when all is said and
done one thing I love about Travis etn
is that he's catching the ball more this
year
i watch the boston college game and the
Wake Forest game was that last week and
Wake Forest and yes last week he is
catching the ball so much more this year
and that was one of my big questions on
him last year was seven seen this guy
catch the ball a lot but this year he's
really doing a good job but I think one
big reason why clemson is clicking they
that offensive line is coming together
and we're seeing it in the run game I
mean it was against Wofford but he had
nine carries for 212 yards like that
that's ridiculous no matter who's you're
playing so I think that's why we're
seeing Lawrence Nietzsche and really
step back to where we thought they were
because of the often
to blind stock up for me the last one
and this is where we live in a society
and we do three podcast a week where
everyone wants instant analysis and with
player evaluation you really can't do
that it's a process it's a five-month
process usually throughout the season
and then postseason and we have to take
our time and let things marinate and
with AJ epinasty the year started and
everyone was like I thought you said
this guy was good he's not getting Sachs
he's not getting TFLs what's going on
well a japanesse in the last three weeks
has basically been unstoppable for Iowa
he is playing exceptional ball and
sometimes guys might dare slow start to
the season for whatever reason but he it
seems like has just really been allowed
to play instinctive football game which
is why I liked him so much coming into
the year I have not moved up announcer
out of my top ten all year just because
I loved what I saw last year enough and
was just waiting for it to not unleash
this year well it has an a japanesse is
still to me looks like the second-best
edge in this class and that's only
because chase young was created in a
laboratory and it's not an actual human
being
Pepin ssize we talked about a mock draft
Monday his ability to play defensive end
to bump down and play in a 4-3 and he's
he's exactly what you want in a modern
defensive lineman
yeah his speed to power is absolutely
ridiculous and you saw him whip up on
some of those interior players this
weekend so an awesome bounce-back
performance for epinet
all right last one here for stock up
it's the Andre Swift yes to Georgia
players from me but I was in Auburn so
I'm biased for this one
listen when you look at a running back
you want to see how they do against
future NFL fronts and Auburn has a lot
of future NFL players on that defensive
line one in Derrick Brown that's gonna
go probably top 15 and Swift averaged
over six yards to carry he looked
explosive he can really do everything
what you love about Swift is you could
probably plug him into any scheme I
would like to see him probably in an
outside zone at the next level but we
can't all get what we want but I think
Swift can be a good interior runner he
could be a good outside runner he has
good burst good vision he makes guys
miss and he knows how to finish runs at
the second level with power so a really
really strong season for DeAndre Swift
and this might have been his top
performance against a good opponent
like I said if G Andre Swift ends up in
Kansas City it's just not fair because
he's so tailor-made for that system in
that scheme all right let's take a break
we come back we're going to fix these
Chicago Bears and boy oh boy do they
need our help
these Chicago Bears were a team expected
to win the NFC North it looks like a
Super Bowl contender
Mitchell drew Biscay was the hottest MVP
bet at the Caesar sports book all summer
long but by the time those preseason got
here and I'll take I'll raise my hand on
this in May I was like I think the Bears
could make the Super Bowl by July when
we had to put in our final 2019 season
projections I was I didn't even predict
them to make the playoffs because
everything you heard coming out of
Chicago was this it doesn't look good
they are really struggling in camp and
you would hear all the time like well
mitch is struggling but it's because our
defense is so good but then like anyone
you talked to who was actually there
observing big this doesn't look that
good he's just he's not playing well and
so here we are the Bears are reeling
it's a bad team right now they have no
first-round pick because of the clear
Mac trade they have no third-round pick
they do have two second-round picks but
Connor this is a team that right now on
paper it looks bad they have 13 and a
half million dollars roughly in salary
cap space they have a collection of
draft picks they have let's see right
they have seven picks but only two of
those from the top 140 right now it's
not good where do you start with this
team that has one year one more year of
Mitchell trip whiskey who's not gonna
get a fifth-year option I would not
think and very limited resources to try
to find someone else to play the
position well I want to kick this back
to you Matt this is what we have to
start with does Matt Negi and/or Ryan
pace survive that's the question Bears
fans have to be asking themselves right
now because when it comes down to it
when you're the GM you often don't get
to pick to franchise quarterbacks right
you get to pick one and if it fails as
miserably as it has for Mitch you
probably are gonna get let go and I
don't know if the Bears are ready to do
that I'll say this like let's go through
their last couple drafts right because
that's the fairway
do it even when you do that when it
comes down to it everybody will look at
the trade up for true Biscay that's the
problem so Ryan pace has been the GM
since 2015 you know there's been a lot
of big misses early on man they haven't
hit you can't say confidently they've
hit on a first rounder maybe ro Quan
Smith but he hasn't been great this year
there was that little absence midseason
as well like Kevin white Leonard Floyd
Mitchell true Biscay ro Quan Smith those
your first-round picks and the best one
was an off ball linebacker which a lot
of them don't go in the top ten and you
look at I mean the Adam Shaheen pick
looks really bad I know Eddie Jackson
was a great find three Cohen was a great
find yeah but you got a hit on some of
these guys at the top and most notably
the quarterback and I think you know the
offensive line is falling apart I don't
know I think the Bears are a really
historic franchise that has a lot of
pull and maybe an opportunity here where
somebody sees the roster specifically
the defense and they go out go in there
because if I get this offense right do
they have to blow it up Matt or you're
just one of these two guys need to be
let go it's it's almost comical to me
because sitting there on day two of the
2017 NFL Draft I mean you sit beside me
during the draft and you know like I'm
furiously texting people while we're on
camera you know trying to get
information try to get stories it's a
huge part of our draft coverage and it
is my favorite part of our draft
coverage and as we were sitting there I
got a text from a person who is very
high up with a team of second-in-command
and said Ryan page just got fired with
this draft he said that day two of the
NFL draft I showed you the text you know
who sent it to me you can vouch for how
high-ranking this person is and that
text that tweet last year people were
just trashing it of oh my god you know
please don't ever use this source again
is that guy still in the NFL how wrong
could a person be this year people are
retweeting that tweet saying I
the Bears need to hire whoever that was
because they had the foresight to say
trading up for Mitch
was a bad idea drafting Adam Shaheen
from Ashland College in round 2 was a
bad idea and we see that now a team that
has mortgaged their future on Khalil
Mack and Mitchell Comiskey and I still
love Khalil Mack he did not register a
stat against the LA Rams this week not a
tackle not a pressure I don't even know
if he farted in the wind and it affected
someone I don't know what he did on the
field really didn't do anything so I
think that yeah you have major questions
about Ryan paces ability this is a dude
who came from New Orleans where he was
more of a cap guy than a scout and I
think it's fair to have questions like
you said we are we've seen 5 draft
classes and have very limited impact
from those so I feel like I'm in a weird
position to call and say you know what
Ryan pace yeah you got to go because
when you trade up and miss on the
quarterback it doesn't matter how good
the defense looked or how close you got
last year it's about the future of this
team and you've also put them in a
salary cap situation where they cannot
easily go out and find a replacement for
true Biscay so I think Ryan pace is at
least on a very hot seat I think Matt
naggy who did not draft Mitchell drew
Biscay he came in after the fact I could
see him staying but he's gonna have to
show the tough decision making ability
to say I don't trust true Biscay I want
someone else and here's what my offense
would look like with someone else
because right now and I I've followed
Matt naggy for years he was in Kansas
City what they're doing offensively in
Chicago I don't recognize like that's
not Kansas City it's not what Andy Reid
does it's not what Doug Peters saying
Frank Reich do I don't even know what
this is trim is obviously holding them
back but I think for naggy to save his
job he's gonna have to say alright
enough is enough this guy's not getting
it done
yeah I'm with you there I think when you
look at naggy he's safe because they won
12 games last year they have not looked
prepared many times this year it's been
a rough four and six
it really has yep but when you look at
it you make a great point Matt he's
probably sitting there with ownership
and going listen get me Mott let me get
my quarterback and I'll get this right
and I think pace you know even though
he's on an extension
that takes him through 2021 that doesn't
mean much in the NFL or anymore it's not
like the ripping up a six-year deal
right there I do think it could be
potentially over for Ryan pace but as
we've seen many times I know it locally
here the Jets have this problem
Washington has this problem bad
franchises have this problem where when
you let go of one of the GM er coach and
the new one is stuck with the other
that's a gigantic risk and that's what
the Bears are gonna have to you know
assess and they're gonna have to speak
with naggy if they move on from Ryan
pace and say hey who is in the league
right now that you'd want to work with
now yeah this is interesting because I
could already see you perking up there's
somebody in Kansas City that probably
makes a lot of sense right you mean me
yeah that's what I was talking about
no Mike Berg on C makes a ton of sense
here I mean it's it's just the natural
progression and yeah if they want to get
someone that naggy trust and they get a
scout that you say okay Matt like you
need someone who can go find players to
fit your scheme that's how harmony works
in a front office look at Eric decosta
and John Harbaugh right now like they're
[ __ ] clicking like perfect because
they understand each other and I think
with burgundy you have a natural a guy
who is has come up through a very good
stable organization he understands
drafting he understands valuation which
i think is the most important factor for
a potential GM candidate it's not just
about being a good Scout when you're the
guy handed in the card it's about is
this player good value at this pick
which is something I think the Bears
have messed up with Ryan pace so
Briganti makes a lot of sense
obviously if naggin wants to give me a
call I will at least listen and you and
Melo can do the podcast now but let's
look at some of the quarterback options
they have again not great because no
first-round pick they do have two
second-round picks but it's unlikely
they could trade either or both of those
picks to get high enough to get adjusted
Herbert or a Joe burrow and there's no
way they're getting Joe burrow so well
they can do Cam Newton will be on the
trade block Teddy Bridgewater free agent
Philip Rivers free agent Marcus Mariota
free agent Ryan Tannehill free agent
none of those names are super sexy if
Cam Newton's healthy we've talked about
this at linked so we don't need to jump
back into it he makes the most sense to
me but you're probably going to have to
trade to get him with no
third round pick and no fourth round
pick you have to wonder if it's that
second one of those two second round
picks that would go to Carolina for Cam
Newton that's the move for me that's
where this really starts and ends
I don't think Teddy who's going to
Chicago I don't think that's I don't
know I'd be really surprised it doesn't
teddy whether it doesn't seem like a fit
I think the most ideal scenario is teddy
takes over in New Orleans I'll just say
it over and over and over again and
Teddy cares a lot about fit because he
passed up on I believe more money from
Miami last year to be the starter their
smart move teddy yep brilliant move that
worked out really well for him I think
he'll have that for side again wherever
he goes cam would be I think of healthy
cam would be great
for Chicago they do have the second
round mo to go get it done when you look
at the other options like Mariota no
thanks no thanks I mean how much of an
upgrade is that it's not fill Phillip
Rivers is probably just gonna hang it up
I think when you look at it it's cam or
you're going into the draft and that's
it's pretty tough man it doesn't leave
you with a lot of solutions it almost
makes it like you have to get it done
yeah it does you can't head into the
strapped and say we'll take jaylen hurts
and we'll figure it out or we'll take
Jordan love and hope that number one
hope nowhere because you don't pick
until 45 overall so it is difficult I
think like you said the move here is if
as long as Cam Newton's healthy you can
get him we've talked before about yes he
counts 19 point 1 million dollar salary
cap they're sitting at thirteen point
seven there's a gap there how long is
that for a team option I love Kyle but
he's been hurt he hasn't played well
he's most likely gone that's going to
save the Chicago Bears a good amount of
money as far as next year goes
Leonard Floyd fit to your option
probably not picking that up because
guess what we need to save more money
there as well so you can look at Kyle
long Adam Shaheen and Leonard Boyd if
they're not on the team next year that's
enough money to go get a Cam Newton and
still have flexibility to you know sign
a couple four agents to get another
corner to maybe get another pass rusher
to get another receiver areas where
they've tried to draft and haven't been
able to find hit so I think you know
Leonard Floyd that's 13 million dollars
that you free up if he's not on the team
next a lot of money so and then guys
like Alan Robinson could be restructures
you know Eddie goldman hasn't played
very well this year after having a
really good 2018 season you have to
wonder if he would restructure at this
point I know that's a new deal but no
Charles Lind another guy has not played
well at left tackle and you can't cut
him because it would be seven and a half
million dollars dead cap but you talked
to these guys about a restructuring a
little bit Prince Amukamara you saved
nine million dollars by cutting that
dude that's a lot of money for a team
that's cap strapped so I think they can
be smart and maybe you know what there's
no dead cap if you trade Leonard Floyd
maybe just ask the Panthers hey do you
want a 2021 third rounder and Leonard
Floyd for Cam Newton who you guys aren't
gonna keep anyway I think that's an
interesting conversation now let's jump
into a mock draft again this team has no
first-round pick so that is huge with
two second-round picks I'm assuming they
filled a quarterback need in free agency
or a trade so I'm not taking a
quarterback early here I want offensive
tackle Jedrek wills plays right tackle
at Bama I think he stays there for
Chicago where Bobby Massey is a great
dude but an average player should
probably be a backup Jedrek will
solidifies helps this run game a little
bit you see how important Mitchell true
Biscay is in the Kansas City offense the
Bears need that too they need to be able
to run the ball right-handed they need
to be able to free up the tight ends to
get into their route trees and not be
blockers Will's helps with that and
though it picked 52 like I said I would
cut Prince Amukamara draft AJ Terrell
from Clemson I think he could come in
and be a good rookie starter especially
in this scheme I think he's very
physical we see a smooth transition in
his backpedals he's a good player that's
falling under the radar a little bit
right now so I went with a little bit of
a different route here and that was the
what if things don't work out for them
in the trade marketer for agencies what
if she can't play that anyway yeah yeah
we got to show both sides of the coin
here what if Jake Fromm is sitting there
at the 45th overall pick now for me that
might be a little bit of a slide I think
he'll go at the top of the second round
but you never know he's not the most
overwhelmingly physical kind of guy I've
already talked to some teams that are
like yeah we'll probably great him as a
great long-term backup a lot of guys are
those grades end up starting at some
point their careers and go much higher
than you think when you look at from if
he's there at 45 and the bear
are stuck with this roster that they
have true Biscay coming back this year
you gotta have someone that is just more
calm more composed somebody that can
control the often somebody that can give
guys like Alan Robinson a chance yeah in
this offense I would take the swing at
Jake from five of Chicago and then
moving on seven pics later second round
again pick 52 I went with Prince tiga
one egg oh I hopefully I said the last
part of it when you look at Prince at
Auburn he's big nasty offensive tackle
with a lot of tools little raw coming
into the year but I think we've seen
growth over this year and I think when
you look at Prince he's gonna be at the
Senior Bowl last time I checked correct
me if I'm wrong I know you Matt but yeah
he'll be at the Senior Bowl a lot of
good defensive line reps will see him
against Javon Kinlaw his teammate
Derrick brown who gives him a lot of
work in practice I think when you look
at him he's gonna be one of those
second-round guys that legitimately has
long term starter potential yeah I like
that fit for them a lot now no
third-round pick no fourth round pick so
the Bears are gonna be taking some naps
and probably I don't get in a game of
golf or something because you're gonna
have a little bit of a break in the
draft room but they do have three picks
in round five there right now all
projected to be really close together so
I'm going to address again some areas
where you have guys that are current
free agents like haha Clinton dicks so
I'm taking shahim Carter safety from
Alabama the other safety at Alabama a
very good strong safety prospects now
you have Eddie Jackson and shahim Carter
in the backend I want to take another
receiver because I think we've seen guys
like Anthony Miller has not stepped up
they need someone opposite Allen
Robinson so a little bit of a project in
collage Lipscomb from Vanderbilt but
someone who when their quarterback was
healthy was a very good producer and
then I'm always gonna be a fan of taking
pass rushers especially in a 3-4 base
defense so Carter Coughlin from
Minnesota those are my 3 round 5 picks
where round 5 listen if the guy makes
the roster you're pretty happy about
that but I like these 3 round 5 players
because I actually believe there are
some starter traits in each of them yes
there are some weaknesses holding them
down but these are three dudes that I
think could play in the NFL yeah I'm
with you all the way I started there at
wide receiver as well I like what Taylor
Gabriel can do for you in the slot he's
under contract like Allen Robinson on
one side but let's go with another big
bodied wide receiver and that's Brian
Edwards
on wet Edwards's they go up and win the
football kind of target that can throw
people around after the catch and if
you're gonna structure an offense with a
limited quarterback say you do get from
or you have Cam Newton who takes
vertical shots you have two big guys on
the outside and Robinson Edwards Gabriel
working the slot I think that's enough
to work with especially with tarik Owen
and David Montgomery in the backfield
this pass catchers keeping it moving in
round five listen you can't you can't
build Rome in one day I know this team
has a lot more offensive line needs I
took Prince tiga at the second round now
let's go and tear your offensive line
Tommy Cramer from Notre Dame just keep
stacking they need bodies they've lost a
lot of bodies this year to injury they
need more depth in the back and the
interior offensive line they're also in
round five god it's just the round five
party for the Bears here I went with
linebacker Joe Bochy
he's gonna fall after the suspension he
had a great start to the year
I still think he has good instincts I
don't I mean when you look at the
suspension this is one of those times
where teams actually might be a little
bothered by it
but at the end of the day the guy could
still play at the minimum he could spear
and a backup yeah it's an again you're
drafting this late like okay he's
probably you're gonna have something
injury athletic limitation PD test drugs
or something like that so round six I
went linebacker here I do think this
didn't neat for them because we have
seen Ron Smith take that out since Danny
Trevathan is a free agent so cliquey
Hudson from Michigan would be my pick
and then round seven I'm finally gonna
draft a quarterback people who listen to
the show three times a week know my
philosophy on this you should draft a
quarterback almost every year and that's
what you do here because you never know
when you're gonna hit or even if you can
just flip the guy for assets it's a
smart move I'm gonna take Anthony Gordon
a one-year starter from Washington State
not the biggest dude in the world but I
think he has a pretty fun arm and Mike
Leach is gonna let you sling it around
so at least get get a guy like this in
camp and see what you've got with
Anthony Gordon alright round six for me
yeah they do need more at corner I liked
what you did in the second round with AJ
Terrell I'm gonna laborat here from
Michigan once again it's tricky for the
Bears because after some cuts some open
up some cap room for a potential
quarterback it might open the door for
some more needs but at least Hill is a
guy that has a lot of playing experience
in the Big Ten and might be able to
actually get on the field for a day
three pick next
year round seven let's have some fun
here speaking of the senior ball safety
probably gonna be linebacker as you told
me before the show here Matt Kyle Duggar
a Division two prospect when you look at
Duggar he is a gigantic safety and in
Division two football he truly does look
like a man amongst boys so we're excited
to see him at the Senior Bowl see how he
can run with those running backs and
tight ends and get more of a hybrid
player for this already impressive Bears
defense oh I love Kyle Duggar that's one
of mine anyone who might like day three
draft crushes this year that you guys
are gonna be so tired of hearing me talk
about but you're here for it so let's
take a break come back we got four
awesome draft on draft questions to end
the show with gets trapped on draft time
we're gonna kick it off with our buddy
Pat Chamberlain first question who are
some potential candidates to skip bowl
games this year to project to protect
excuse me their NFL future this is
always a tough question because we saw
last year it's like it's not just the
top guys you know we've seen average
players like Jeff percent of Texas skip
their bowl game so it's not just Isiah
Simmons well they'll be in the playoffs
so he wouldn't be a good candidate
anyway but Derrick brown Auburn like
that would be one that would interest me
but he just doesn't seem like that kind
of dude you know he doesn't slam a toe
you maybe if they don't make the playoff
because especially right now he's
dealing with a head injury
I could actually I think CD lamb is a
really good one because you don't want
to risk a lower body injury
I mean Vaart you've been a little bit
banged up already this year i CD lamb it
would be near the top of my list
CJ Henderson probably will just because
he seems like that kind of guy you know
he's a sort of guy worried about myself
we're not good anyway so
deuces I'm out of here I'll tell you one
that should skip and I don't think he
will is Jonathan Taylor Oh 6,000 yards
Jonathan Taylor should not play in
whatever [ __ ] ballgame Wisconsin is
in yeah kid come on the Alamo Bowl
chumma Hubbard Yahoo he's coming out
actually that's true it's been up in
there that has been up in the air for a
while yeah yeah CD is like the big name
you have to put hey [ __ ] Alabama might
be in a bowl game this year Matt
No yeah like all those guys although
nick saban would literally kill him so
it's like jerry judy trying to spit out
the sugar bowl or whatever like I don't
I don't think it's I don't think a
single wide receiver that's eligible for
Alabama would play drugs no way without
both probably not no [ __ ] that the
Netherlands and Jalen Waddell show now
she shouldn't yeah that's a fun it's a
fun question because it makes a lot of
people mad like people get so triggered
by guys not playing in ball games but
Alabama could still make the playoff I
know a lot of people like Pamela's done
and maybe because she was hurt but if
LSU beats Georgia and SEC championship
game which we will be at then Alabama
would be as long as they went out they
would probably be number four yeah
that's true I don't know I if you
remember I picked Georgia to win the SEC
and I'm like just sitting here like
maybe you never know probably not but
you never know this is like when I
picked the Jets to win four games and I
did as well and they feel like there's
no way and then like all the like well
yeah no way I could have seen this
happening the way it did but the end
result take it
exactly right take it all right Justin
Tarbell been a while buddy people
usually hate on John Lynch as a GM with
San Francisco success this year has that
perception changed at all I don't know
because I think you could look at what
like why are the Niners winning they've
had a ton of early draft picks and those
guys are playing well like DeForest
Buckner Arik Armstead and Nick Bosa were
all very early draft picks and they're
playing well they traded for and somehow
got the bargain in the century for a
very good quarterback and they got in
for a second-round pick so I think when
you look at the Niners draft you're not
gonna be blown away like you're I wrote
an article it came out Tuesday morning
and it was the best draft classes of the
last decade the Niners aren't on there
like they just they have not drafted
that well they've had some good players
but right now you don't have that
overwhelming class of like oh my god
this was the turning point you know like
Dante Pettis is a bust
Salomon Thomas is a bust Rueben Foster
is a bust
they took C
better than the third round that's a bad
pick there Joe Williams yeah there's
still a lot of bad picks here so 2017 I
guess was the first year for John so you
can't say like divorce Buckner and our
Armstead were his but those still really
early picks and that's why they're
playing well I think what's James John
is that Mike McGlinchey even though he's
been hurt this year was a good pick
Fred Warner in the third round that's
proven to be a good pick Joanne Kittel
yep George Kittel great pick in round
five so he's had those like mid to late
picks that are kind of saving his resume
right now yeah I was just gonna say that
that's really what it comes down to is
that they've hit on some back end guys
and it feels like this year was the
first year he did it the standard way
like Nick Bosa is an absolute stud
second overall
Deebo Samuel in the second round is
really really coming on lately Jimin
Hurd is hurt and you can't sit here I go
we couldn't have seen that coming cuz
Jalen Hurd was always hurt in college
but I like that risk in the third round
yeah this was the year where it's like
okay the top picks hit but all those
other years yeah he did struggle on some
really key picks so it's it's somewhere
in the middle now what I will say is
this if Kyle Shanahan ever gets someone
in there
that's not average at this but good at
this they'd be a problem for a long time
I mean if you give Kyle really good
personnel not just good personnel they
they could be in the NFC Championship
game every year yeah that's how good he
is the defense is so good as well like I
mean is hard to keep everyone but I mean
it's good it's really good but they they
need to find someone who can scout
corners and receivers because that's
where they need help right now and
that's so hard cuz there you go to fill
so how close are Jerry Judy and CD lamb
is draft prospects on my board they are
closely ranked Judy's at three lambs at
nine as I was saying earlier in the show
though there are some gaps where it's
like Oh three to nine doesn't seem that
big it actually kind of is and that will
be reflected when we put number grades
on players for me they are I mean I like
them both a lot but I don't think
they're that close
so I've Judy at two and
df5 and OCD I'll move up now over to ax
so be like two and four and that'll
probably a lot of change I think they're
close man and it's tricky because
they're so different that is they're so
freakin different like Judi the routes
are flawless he's electric after the
catch there's some really annoying drops
lately that I think are kind of
uncharacteristic right you still sit
there and go okay and what CD it's like
he just wants to bully the [ __ ] out of
you and there's so many times for
college receivers that do that and you
go that ain't gonna work at the next
level what CD it is he he wins he wins
at the catch point he wins in his routes
by just beating the [ __ ] out of you I'll
run through you that there's a different
dog in CD I think Jerry Judy is a little
more athletically gifted well I think CD
has an extra edge that's just nasty and
that's why I think they're close I wish
I could give CD Lam Judy's agility and
speed and I wish I could give Judy CD
Lambs like mentality because yeah that
like they would be the perfect receiver
if you blended them together I think the
reason that I like Judy so much better
is a good route running translates they
always he's safer he's significantly
safer if you look at the receivers that
I've liked and hit on it's because
they're good route runners and they
don't drop the ball that's where Judy
scares me because he's body catching
more this year and it's just it there's
no reason for it I mean he's not a type
of receiver with lamb my only question
is can he separate at the next level
because he's not a fast guy if you watch
him play I mean he does catch a lot of
wide open passes I think some of that is
the scheme so I don't watch CD lamb and
say like [ __ ] that dudes a clean route
runner it's more god I love him after
the catch and I love his catch radius
like he's just he is always physical
he's not afraid to traffic he'll catch
the ball around you know if there's a
bunch of guys around but a lot of times
he's wide open and I think that's not
his fault scheme is just really good so
I wonder how well he'll be able to
separate against good corners the next
level but like you said they're both top
ten players for me and I really think
they're fantastic
I don't have a vote if I did for the
ability kaufe ward it would be seedy
lamb he's the
receiver in college football this year
yeah I agree with you and it's also one
of those times where you know we
probably will get these guys on the
podcast I hope we do we're you really
would love to just talk to them and and
feel them out and see what makes them as
good as they are and sometimes that
could be a big difference because a
position like wide receiver as we've
seen over the years has all kinds of
personalities and that can really
dictate how good a guy is gonna be I
think it's something that people loved
about depo last year you know debo was
it's all business all business physical
nasty great demeanor and you're seeing
that translate already under Shanahan
alright last question of today's show
from David Botsford the Steelers need a
playmaker wide receiver to go with juju
should they draft one in the second
round or sign a free agent and he's put
in parentheses Dez Bryant or terrelle
pryor
that's either of those variations would
be guys I would go after I've had
Steeler fans ask me a lot lately like
hey how can we fix this this year you
can't really because you know it's just
it's after the trade deadline anyone
that's out there on the street is not
that good of a player and I think you
can look at the upcoming free agent
class at wide receiver it's not that
good I mean you want to sign Robbie
Anderson who's gonna be 28 years old I I
mean there there's some speedy receiver
but there's a risk to that you know if
you're gonna sign Amari Cooper so I
think round two is where you do this or
even you know round three this is a
really deep wide receiver class someone
we've talked a lot about before the
Steelers couldn't do it around three
excuse me they don't have around three
pick right now so they only have five
selections before compensatory picks are
awarded so it does make it difficult but
I picked 47 I mean there's a chance you
could get a low viscous ain't no who's
gonna give you speedy at the position
you know that they're they're a good
group of receivers I think guys might
even fall a little bit because of it but
Brandon I okay Arizona State yeah
they're made to be a Pittsburgh Steeler
with his run after catch ability Michael
Pittman junior at USC not a speed guy
but a very physical receiver so there
there are a lot of round to players that
I would put in there we got to see what
happens with sage Surat at Wake Forest
whose hurt now out for the year I
believe he will declare as a redshirt
sophomore KJ Hamlin another redshirt
sophomore that was thinking so there
there are some good receivers in round
two you know you got the Michigan guys I
think Donovan Peebles Jones - probably
second round pick so it's a good year to
need a receiver and I wouldn't be
surprised if we see you know Pittsburgh
even in that position if they wanted to
try to trade back not far but trade back
to try to get a couple more picks
because where they have needs this year
I think matches up really well with this
draft strength yeah I would love to see
them get someone that could stretch the
field and give these guys a little more
room and KJ would really fit the bill
for that and I think I you quit - I
think you need somebody that's gonna run
really well and the problem is you could
say that about all three of the Alabama
guys but they're all going to the first
round so you can you can cross that one
off unless the Steelers want to be ultra
aggressive again and come back up for a
player which I don't think they need to
do that franchise develops wide
receivers as good as anyone and I think
there'll they'll be in a good place the
bigger question for me is you know Big
Ben will be back next year but at some
point this team has to think quarterback
of the future is not mr. Rudolph it's
most definitely not Mason Rudolph man as
man I I'm not even gonna get into it
because we could do another hour on the
whole fight situation but I am NOT a
Mason Rudolph fan I would just like to
say that that's something we were
talking about the other day is nope not
at all
and it surprised me how many people
around the NFL are not either before the
fight even but I thought the same thing
and this is not absolving miles garret
of in any way in any possible way but
there were definitely some problems on
Mason's end in the beginning of that
fight yeah listen it went both ways that
guy he's like your buddy and he like
starts talking [ __ ] in a bar and you're
like damn and then you're stuck in it
and you're like what the [ __ ] can we
just go out one night and not get into a
fight like why do you got to run your
mouth yeah yeah and then add a kid so
muscles and then you're pissed cuz like
hey that's not okay that's my friend and
you just assaulted them right well an
ass have to jump in what goddamn mess do
you see that coming in the blind review
right see that one coming
all right that's a Rudolph so there it
is that is our show we'll be back Friday
morning college football seasons getting
to a close so we're gonna have some fun
talking about I think we're gonna get
into some of the best of the decade
stuff because the decades ending as is
college football so we have a lot to get
into on the Friday morning show don't
forget Saturday will be at Stanford come
find us on the Grove 8:00 a.m. and the
tailgate guys village ricotta it's Matt
we'll talk to y'all real soon